ينضم الينا من الرباط الشاعر والاديب
والمؤرخ جمال بن حويربه المستشار الثقفي
في حكومه دبي اهلا بك نورنا يسعد صباحك
شكرا على تواجدك معانا استاذ جمال
الله يصبحكم بالخير والسرور
مكانه اللغه العربيه بوصفها في يومها
حضاريا للتراث والثقافه والفكر احدى ركائز
الحضاره البشريه
اللغه العربيه استمرت برابط او اكثر من 8
حروف وعاء من المعرفه والعلم
لا توجد لغه في العالم
بلغت مبلغ اللغه العربيه في التاريخ
اللغه الانجليزيه 100 وشوي سنه
وقبلها اللغه الالمانيه
اما قبل ذلك كانت اللغه العربيه هي اللغه
التي تهيمين على
معرفه والعلوم بها مناسبه
وهذه ليست شهادتي انا ولكن شهاده كل
العلماء الذين اخروا للعلم
في تاريخ الانسان
بلغته التي ان شاء الله قريبا نراها لغه
ايضا للعلم
استكمالا لمسيرتها الخالده
نعم استاذ جمال في
الشعر لك المحبه ذوق وحدود ورموز من عرف
قانونها ما غشها من قصيده رموز لك هل
الاتجاه الشعر اليوم اقرب لي العمليه ليصل
الى قلوب الناس اكثر منهم من اللغه
العربيه الفصحى ما رايك
بنت الفصحى كل المفرداتها هي مفردات نصيحه
واللغه العاميه ليس لا تبعد كثيرا عن
الفصحى
فمن همم اتقن العاميه بسهوله يدرس الاعراب
وهمم الصرف يستطيع ان يتكلم الفصحى بشكل
همم صحيح بعكس من ليس يتقن من لا يتقن
العاميه غير العرب اهو فانهم لا يستطيعون
الحديث باللغه العربيه الا بعد جهد جيد
فالعاميه في الوطن العربي كله ليس في
الخليج فقط هي بنت الفسحه
يتعلم الاعراب يتعلم بالصرف ثم يتقن اللغه
العربيه فاللغه العربيه هي باقيه في
اللهجاتها العاميه حتى اليوم حتى تبقى
اللغه العربيه استاذ جمال يعني اللغه
العربيه لغه
تعلمها والاهتمام فيها في كل مجالات
حياتنا
اتفق العلماء كلهم ان لغه او ان الابداع
لا يكون الا بلغه الامه الانجليزي
عليه ان يتعلم الانجليزيه ليبدع
والالماني عليهم يتعلم الالمانيه ليبدع
وايضا العربي يجب ان يبدع بلغته الام حتى
يصل قمه الابداع اذا لم يكتب او يبدع
ويبتكر بلغته الام فان الابداع يكون
منقوصا ولا يصل الى الجروح هذا اتفق عليه
العلماء بلا اي جدال لهذا نقول لجميع
العرب
اللغه العربيه هي لغتكم الام اذا لم
تتقنوها
وتبتكر بها وتكتب ابحاثكم
والابحاثكم
وتنشره العلم بلغتكم الام لن تصل الى فقط
اليوم عندما تطالبون بالحفاظ على اللغه
العربيه كاللغه ام وبالتالي التركيز عليها
هل نعني هنا بالدرجه الاولى ان تكون اللغه
العربيه فصحى خالصه ام ان العاميه هي ابنه
اللغه الفصحى
اللغات الهجات العاميه هي ذكرت انها ابنه
الفصحى لكن كل مدينه كل منطقه لها اسلوب
في نطق المفردات لهذا لا يجمعها جميعا الا
الفصحى لو كانت الاخبار
مثلا الان نتكلم بالعاميه هناك عدد من
العرب لم يفهم بهذا جميع الاخبار والمشرات
الاخباريه ومعظم القنوات التلفزيونيه تنطق
باللغه العربيه الفصحى ليكون الفهم عامه
كذلك من يتعلم اللغه العربيه من خارج
الوطن العربي يحتاج ان يستمع الى الفصحى
لانه لا يفهم العاميه العاميه تعين على
الوصول الى الفصحى ولكنها ليست هي المعين
المعين الذي لا ينضب والقوه القاهره
والكبرى هي اللغه العربيه الفصحى التي
تعد اكبر
لغه او اقوى واكثر لغه
في المفرداتها وفي اساليبها واختصارها هي
اللغه الوحيده الاكثر اختصارا في العالم
لا توجد اي لغه حتى في دكان اصطناعي هي
اقرب لي ان تكون اللغه المؤهله
يعني تثبت وتتفوق في الذكاء عليه السلام
اما
اما الوطن العربي في كل مكان له لهجه لا
يجمعها جميعا الا الفصحى والاهميه اهميه
كبيره جدا حتى في التقنيات عندما نعرب
نعرب بالفصحى لو يعربنا باللهجات لا
يفهمها المغربي لن يفهم على المشرق وهكذا
لغه القران الكريم لا تموت من الرباط
الشاعر والاديب والمؤرخ جمال المستشار
الثقافي في حكومه دبي شكرا جزيلا لك